dans le port d'ars guinée guînes dans
l'île de grande canarie 2000 migrants se
retrouvent bloqués dans des conditions
précaires
après leur arrivée par la mer début
novembre les centres d'accueil de
l'archipel ayant atteint leur capacité
maximale
un nouveau camp a été monté près de las
palmas de son décès demandeurs d'asile
ils ont été transférés ce jeudi
l'arrivée de ces migrants près de la
plus grande ville des canaris n'est pas
forcément vu d'un très bon oeil par les
locaux où seront ils dans la rue comment
vont-ils vivre que vont-ils manger s'ils
n'ont pas dead s'ils n'ont pas de
revenus et bien ce qu'on pense c'est
qu'ils vont voler nos sacs ou qu'ils
vont nous attaquer cela me rend très
triste
ça me fait beaucoup de peine parce que
ce sont aussi des êtres humains ils ont
donc aussi le droit au bonheur et je
pense aussi que cela va générer beaucoup
d'insécurité dans les îles canaries
alors que les gens se sont déjà en
insécurité depuis des mois et donc
encore plus maintenant mon charmant
bourg cadeaux ces personnes cherchent
une meilleure qualité de vie mais le
problème doit être résolu à la source
plus de 16 mille migrants irréguliers
sont arrivés dans l'archipel depuis le
début de l'année un nombre près de dix
fois supérieur à celui de 2010 9
toujours aussi problématique
la question migratoire est au centre des
discussions entre les pays de l'union
européenne
en septembre dernier la commission
européenne a présenté un nouveau pacte
sur l'immigration et l'asile une réforme
sur laquelle l'ensemble des pays
européens ont du mal à se mettre
d'accord
la pologne la république tchèque et la
hongrie refusant d'accueillir des
migrants sur leur territoire
lors d'une conférence virtuelle organisé
par le parlement européen et l'allemagne
la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen a appelé
les 27 à être solidaires les uns avec
les autres
decraene système non le système actuel
ne fonctionne plus notre nouveau pacte
sur l'immigration et l'asile permette un
nouveau départ et bien après cela c'est
clair et je me dois de vous le dire une
solution sur la migration qui satisfait
pleinement tout le monde n'existe pas
nantes
reste la pandémie de qu'ovide 19 à
renforcer les difficultés liées au
phénomène migratoire la précarité
omniprésente dans les campements rend
les migrants d'autant plus vulnérable
coronavirus l'accès à un vaccin quand ce
dernier sera disponible et donc une
question primordiale aux yeux de
l'organisation internationale pour les
migrations
l'accès aux soins de santé des migrants
présentes dans les pays européens sera
fondamental mais quand nous avons
maintenant des nouvelles d'un vaccin
le défi auquel vous êtes un membre
européen être confrontés et de garantir
l'accès au vaccin à tous ceux qui se
trouvent sur notre territoire pas
seulement à vos citoyens mais aussi à
tous les réfugiés les personnes
déplacées et les migrants qui se
trouvent en europe les efforts pour
éviter de voir à nouveau les flux
migratoires devenir hors de contrôle
comme en 2015 les 27 pays de l'union
européenne vont devoir trouver un
compromis des efforts sont nécessaires
pour mettre fin au plus vite à
l'entassement des migrants dans des
campements
conçu initialement comme une solution à
court terme